[Music]
and welcome to Hannity and tonight so
January 6 is now dominating the news
cycle all over the country msdnc fake
news CNN uh in Washington Democrats
Capitol Hill and others seething with
rage but per usual they're not telling
the full story in fact they are omitting
a very critical element of that fateful
day how did rioters breach one of the
most important buildings in the most
fortified city in America on a day when
the vice president and almost every
lawmaker was inside and when everyone
knew there was going to be a big rally
expected at the Capitol that day now
coming up tonight the person who was
serving as the capitol police chief on
January 6 Stephen's son he will join us
and help answer that question and it's
an extremely important question as I
said at the time the January 6 committee
they had a predetermined outcome to go
after Donald Trump bludgeon him as much
as possible and that's why Congressman
Jim Jordan Congressman Jim Banks were
off the committee they were kicked off
to committee and only members that
impeached Donald Trump were allowed on
the committee not exactly a fair
committee now sadly Democrats are not
interested in learning how the capital
is breached why security failed so badly
but here's the saddest part to me and it
should be to the whole country and that
is this whole Saga it is the the buried
key and important information that we
now know about intelligence that they
had that was being ignored in the
lead-up to January 6 and they should
have come up with a comprehensive
security plan to ensure this could never
ever happen again like securing a
perimeter kind of like at the White
House you know they have those concrete
barriers that prevent you from getting
on 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue then they
have the big wrought iron fencing we
should all agree on this point this is
not a political Point protect affecting
our institutions like our capital and
every elected official regardless of
party it needs to be a top priority but
for Democrats and others politicizing
something in this case smearing Donald
Trump was the only thing that seemed to
matter to that committee but you don't
have to take good old Sean Hannity's
word for it to their credit even NBC
News pointed out all of this during a
report this year a little late but they
pointed it out good for them
now to our NBC News exclusive the
January 6 committee's final report was
more than 800 pages but some material
did not make the cut including much of
its findings on the failures of federal
law enforcement leading up to the attack
the chief investigator of the January 6
committee says the government could have
prevented it had law enforcement
agencies acted on the available
intelligence do you believe the attack
on the capitol could have been
successfully repelled I think it would
have been a lot different had law
enforcement taken a more assertive
protective posture the Intel in advance
was pretty specific and it was enough in
our view for law enforcement to have
done a better job operationalizing a
secure perimeter law enforcement had a
very direct role in contributing to
certainly the failures the security
failures that led to the violence people
familiar with the committee's work tell
NBC News members downplayed that finding
because they wanted to keep the focus on
former president Trump committee members
dispute
would not discuss internal deliberations
was this an intelligence failure it was
not an intelligence failure
speeds alive
[Applause]
says the committee found the FBI the
Department of Homeland Security and
other agencies did not act on the
intelligence they had including this
online threat forwarded to Capitol
Police January 5th calling on thousands
to go to Washington and help storm the
capital in a statement to NBC News the
FBI said it sent all the intelligence it
had to the Capitol Police
so the partisan Trump hating January 6
committee with a predetermined outcome
sadly buried the security breakdowns
from its reports even though the
committee's own Chief investigator found
quote a lot of advanced intelligence
about law enforcement about carrying
weapons about the vulnerability of the
capital and quote the Intel in advance
was pretty specific and it was enough in
our view for law enforcement to have
done a better job now think about this
security officials Washington D.C they
knew a massive crowd is going to be
gathering for a rally only blocks away
from the capitol on January 6th in the
days the weeks leading up to January 6
the FBI other Federal security agencies
they were tracking what they described
as a large volume of intelligence
showing violent agitators plotting
planning scheming and attack on our
Capital the U.S Capitol and yet a few
hundred Capitol Police were left to fend
for themselves on a massive Capital
complex spanning multiple huge buildings
with dozens of entrances on one of the
most important days of the year so the
question is how on Earth did this happen
and why was this not the main focus of
this failed committee they could have
gone after Trump and they could have
done this part of the job that mattered
too frankly which was more important to
prevent it from ever happening again the
Capitol Police Chief at the time Stephen
Sund was begging for help before the
riot but according to send his request
for the National Guard were rejected or
delayed six separate times watch this
from just the news when I asked Paul
Irving for the National Guard he used
the term Optics and what's interesting
is I'm on the phone with the Pentagon at
9 34 begging for the National Guard to
deploy to assist my men and women and um
Lieutenant General piad is using the
term concern for the Optics I'll never
forget it quote I'm concerned of the
Optics of The Middle military standing
in line with the capital in the
background
so here they are both using the exact
same term when you see the level of
intelligence now that was out there
you're just dumbfounded by it
um that didn't that didn't incur those
were lessons we should have learned from
September 11th that we still haven't
learned by January 6th intelligence was
treated completely different on January
6th and it usually is for major events
in Washington DC
Optics could there possibly be a worse
optic than what we saw on January 6 and
on such an important day why take the
risk protecting members of Congress the
vice president and president of our our
Capital should take priority should they
not not Optics but instead of digging
into these security failures Democrats
they conducted multiple investigations
and of course their impeachment and a
January 6 committee uh that Focus almost
solely on Donald Trump and now there's
no plan to prevent this from ever
happening again and because of their
anti-trump rage they're not even able to
conduct a serious investigation into a
riot that they have been obsessing about
for more than two years and no safety
measures have been put in place pretty
hypocritical and it's also dangerous
especially from a group of people who
never really seemed to care about the
rights this was political bludgeoning
for them and about real Safety and
Security on January 6th now we all
remember for example in the summer of
574 violent riots that summer Democrats
all but they either told you nothing or
they ignored them or they lied to you
and told you they were mostly peaceful
what happened we had dozens of dead
Americans we had thousands of injured
cops they were hit with rocks and
Bottles a Molotov cocktails and worse we
saw looting in arson on a massive scale
billions and billions of dollars worth
of property damage zero investigations
from Democrats in Congress no
investigations into high-ranking
politicians like Kamala Harris that were
out there supporting bail funds for the
people involved in these quote
activities the rioting others were
pouring fuel on the fire by vilifying
cops and pushing the defund dismantled
no bail laws of police departments they
did nothing as a federal courthouse in
Portland was lit on fire over and over
and over and over again there was isn't
one single solitary committee meeting or
committee put together to look into
those 574 riots they ignored the right
of the White House where Secret Service
officers were attacked you may recall
and the president was forced to evacuate
that night to a bunker most Americans
deplore all violent rights we condemn
every one of them we condemned January 6
in real time on my radio show and right
here that night on this show most
Americans want our elected officials
regardless of what their party
affiliation is to be safe and protected
this needs to transcend politics you
would think this is something Democrats
Republicans should be you know
protecting together and by the way that
would also include Supreme Court
justices they should be protected there
are laws against people protesting in
front of their homes but we're not
enforcing those laws for many Democratic
politicians a violent Riot is a
political opportunity why I guess they
think they can round their base or
certainly they don't want to alienate
their base and maybe that's why they
weren't and aren't focused on very real
security failures at the Capitol on
January 6 or maybe it's because a
prominent Democrat is to blame for those
security failures according to the
former Capitol Police Chief Steven Sun
who will join us in a minute the house
sergeant-at-arms turned down his
National Guard requests prior to January
6 because quote I will never get this by
Pelosi hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else